arrived in Argentina last December she's
from Russia but decided to leave her
country because of the war in Ukraine
she was 28 weeks pregnant when she
landed in Buenos Aires now she has a son
Leonel who was born in January and named
after Argentina's football star Lionel
Messi
in September last year we noticed
meanwhile being recruited and there was
a risk my husband could be forced to
join the Army so he decided to leave my
husband traveled first to Armenia and
Tokyo while I stayed to get our children
ready
Maria is not the only Russian who has
come to Argentina and recent months
thousands of Russian women have come to
Argentina to give birth people from
Russia do not need a visa to enter this
country and their children born here can
apply for their nationality according to
Argentine law their families can also
apply through citizenship something that
is an appealing option for Russians who
are hoping to get another passport
a Russian passport is far more limited
internationally than an Argentine one
and authorities here have started to
question the women on arrival some were
told it could be deported and needed
legal assistance to remain in the
country
[Music]
we noticed some tickets only had
reservations and no return tickets so we
had to check whether they were faking
why they were coming some of the women
were 33 weeks pregnant and wouldn't give
a proper reason for coming which sounded
the alarm to the immigration officers
has set up a service to assist people
from Russia who want to move to
Argentina
he also helps women find a doctor a
hospital and get their papers in order
with the Argentine passport you have
more than 170 countries open for you and
I made a table comparing the passports
of Argentina with other countries in the
region and I realize Argentina is the
best one and it's legal and that's why
I'm helping those who want to come here
to give birth
Argentina's authorities say that many of
those seeking citizenship for their
children are exploiting Argentina's laws
and have no intention of staying after
the passport is granted
but there are others like Maria who say
they have come to Buenos Aires to make
it their home
Buenos Aires